i really resist paranoia
i i don't believe in conspiracy theories
or
i don't believe that uh anybody is
running the world i think it has a life
of its own
i think that uh
i agree with you
the major task is is
the task of working on oneself
but not entirely to the exclusion
of
social responsibility
the major contribution most people can
make in the theater of social
responsibility is clarity of thought and
intention
the general
tone of the discussion
arises out of the quality of the people
participating in it
and
you can reach most people
if you will start with something that
they're familiar with and then try and
lead them out of it
i mean i'm amazed in all the years that
i've been talking about the things that
i'm talk about i have never been heckled
ever
no one has ever stood up quaking with
righteous wrath and quoted chapter and
verse or
denounced me and
it's because i will argue with anybody
uh unto the ninth hour if necessary i
really think that the best ideas will
come to the fore and that no there are
no evil
people there is no no group that with
you know demonic cackles
runs off to pollute or make war it's
just that we must change our minds we
all are capable of irrational behavior i
mean who among us cannot think back on
our own behavior to
moments that hardly exemplify the guy
and ethic
so then how can we expect more or
anything better than that from other
people
uh the real task i think is one of
linking together through communication
which people don't realize when they're
not communicating but what we're doing
right now this is very
very unusual activity
even the most intelligent of us go
through our ordinary day basically with
grunts and groans
that's how we signal to each other but
creating a shared mind space a consensus
of understanding requires people talking
to each other and clearly speaking from
the heart about what they know and
understand ralph introduced me to the
notion of claire parlance
this is a psychic ability that we're
trying to cultivate
claire parlance
is
clear speech
you know william blake said the truth
cannot be told so as to be understood
without being believed
that's the greatest weapon the truth is
has but if it is articulated and you
hear it
you will
serve it
and so will george bush and so will
anybody else who hears it the power of
the truth is its immediate limpid
rightness
and
so cognitive activity
and this really goes back to the theme
of the weekend which is shamanism to my
mind what shamans really are are people
who indulge who indulge in cognitive
activity they communicate they dance
they sing they chant they tell stories
they speak out they orate they pray they
communicate and in so doing they
they empower everyone around them to
open their hearts and their minds reagan
was a shaman there is a shaman oh yes
it's stage magic
and there is this com and you can't
understand why
it works
and it does and it is morally neutral
this is the other thing i mean gerbils
you can forget ronald reagan this is a
[ __ ] and a buffoon
joseph goebbels
was a man who understood the power of
information and communication
and if he believed the best idea wins
then he can only shake his head the fate
that overtook his ideas because here was
a millennial dream that 12 years after
it was launched people were living in
basements on rats
so it's a matter of allowing the ideas
to fully express themselves through us
we can only advance into the future
at the rate at which we can transform
our language
and we can only transform our language
by working with it this is why design
and art and music and all of these
things are so important the artist
who appears to be the weakest among us
actually creates the context for
everything to happen in
so that it's so bizarre to hear
right-wing popul
politicians for instance talk about
terms like spin
and hype
and i mean they use the language
by by grafting certain concepts onto the
language you make it impossible for
people not to agree with you you
actually foreclose the option
of disagreement
they know this and we know this so this
is the theater where the battle goes
back and forth to say what the world is
in such a way that you convince everyone
and then we can get down to the business
of living in that world and history
really is this process of trying to
generate a guiding image that serves and
so someone christ muhammad buddha will
project the guiding image and it gels in
the unconscious and becomes a creode and
a vast set of historical forces follow
it the way water follows a dry arroyo
but then
the way is lost it's not clear which
direction the flow should go then there
must be a new guiding image and i think
that the guiding image that we have been
operating under which is the property
owning male citizen
is giving way to a new guiding image
which is
the
the
planetary steward
androgyne
shaman
and this image
reconnects us to nature
reconnects us to the lost part of
ourselves and will serve then
until circumstances change and then it
too will have to yield to some new
definition because we are ultimately
malleable we are like water we achieve
we
take upon ourselves the shape of the
container into which we are poured
and this is what history is is the
flowing from one container to another
[Music]
you